Speaker 1: Let's talk a little bit about the
Canadian trucker convoy.
This is, you know, it's I don't want to say
rare, but it's not super common that something
that really starts in Canada and remains in
Canada for so long become such a major U.S.
story.
The U.S. is very U.S. centric, as many of
you, I'm sure, know.
But part of the reason why the Canadian trucker
convoy has become such a big story in the
United States is that it's become sort of
a pet issue for right wing media.
Right wing media has been supporting and inciting
the trucker convoy, making them out to be
heroes.
If you look on Twitter, there's all sorts
of folks, including former leftists and right
wingers and so on and so forth, saying This
is just it's incredible freedom.
These people are just doing an incredible
thing.
Never mentioning the radical right wing nationalist
and xenophobic roots and organizers involved
in the Canadian trucker convoy, not mentioning
that many of the mandates that they are supposedly
protesting against are being slowly dropped
anyway as an as sort of logical based on what's
going on with COVID numbers, they're not doing
any of that stuff.
But this week, something very interesting
happened, which is on the Fox News program.
The five Geraldo Rivera, who I'm not like
a fan of Geraldo, so he was a Trump guy.
He said a lot of things that don't make any
sense, but every once in a while, Geraldo
will say, it's a broken clock.
That's right.
Every once in a while, he will call out Fox
when they are peddling disinformation or inciting
or spreading propaganda or whatever.
And her, although had the audacity, I guess
we would say, to tell the people on the five,
you guys have been inciting these protests.
You guys have been inside.
They don't have that much support in Canada.
Let's take a look at it and the panel very,
very triggered by heraldo killing it.
Speaker 2: Well, you know, as it relates to
that, Trudeau, in order to, I understand that
in order to to use this National Public Emergency
Act, parliament has to put his imprimatur
on it.
So no know within two weeks parliament has
to vote on it.
My understanding is not that popular in Canada.
How is it going to put bring this to an end?
You know, it is not that popular in Canada.
Judge, is this trucker, this freedom convoy,
right?
What about the freedom of the Hono homeowners
to live in peace?
What about the freedom of the shop keepers
to do business?
What about the freedom of the
Speaker 1: heraldo when it's Black Lives Matter
or and the nebulous antifa protesting?
That's when you care about traffic, people
getting to work businesses, etc.
When it's the trucker convoy, you don't you're
not supposed to care about it
Speaker 2: auto workers to get parts so they
can keep their cars when they were burning
down the federal courthouse in Seattle.
He did.
I did that.
I condemn this.
Speaker 1: And the funny thing is that line
plays well.
Whoa, Judge Jeanine really got him on his
hypocrisy.
No heraldo has been clear.
No matter who's protesting, he doesn't want
destruction of property.
Fires blocking traffic.
Speaker 2: Whatever it condemn anybody who
who feels so he did it.
But what violence so empowered that they can
take away your rights to establish their rights?
What rights are not taking away?
They're taking away the right of the homeowner
to sleep in peace that is of the shopkeeper
to do business.
What are you the right of the Auto Workers
Party?
These rights are be taken away.
They're not marking houses.
They are part of the people down to the middle
of the night that they're actually being welcome.
You are, you are.
This conservative means you have one person.
You're talking to your candidate.
It is conservative media that is that is has
gone from support to incitement, despite these
are violating the rights of others in Canada.
They say we're inciting the polls that I see
the Harb Ledger Ipsos.
These polls all show between sixty five and
sixty nine percent of Canadians oppose these
truckers because this has gone on long enough.
Oh, that's a big show.
The evidence show.
Yeah, they have a very short open your eyes
and look, no, no, I'm actually I actually
read and do research.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
Well, the research seems to have confused
Greg Gutfeld very, very significantly.
But her, although, is absolutely right.
And then they start fighting about who is
actually more working class in this entire
thing.
Speaker 2: I think they have to stop roll
backs, and Justin Trudeau knows these workers
for a year.
Yes, two years, excuse me.
And made them go to work every day.
Call them essential.
Basically didn't provide them with what they
needed.
And then in one stroke of a pen.
I don't know
Speaker 1: how funny is that, because that's
what we did in the United States, too under
Trump.
Make them go to work.
Don't give them the things they need, except
by by, you know, it's like pulling teeth.
But they they were defending Trump's handling
of COVID.
Speaker 2: Days that actually are no longer
essential workers.
Yeah, they are.
You're nonessential.
Yes, very rude.
But I got it before it, I have to respond
to this because rather says blanketed right
wing media is inciting and essentially
Speaker 1: he's also implicating us because
we are
Speaker 2: defending you.
Speaker 1: We are exactly right that in Heraldo
is correct to do so.
Speaker 2: I'm OK with that because the fact
is we've always been on the right side.
We are not like the right side.
We're not the right.
We're not.
We're not like
Speaker 1: her other by now.
You're on the political right, but not on
the correct side.
Speaker 2: Silverado, which has a disdain
for the working class.
Oh no, no.
I am not working in that Bentley, right?
Go driving to your pants after 50 years of
hard work and more charity than you'll ever
do in your entire life.
My point is you don't like these guys coming
up first
Speaker 1: via, you know, Heraldo has a lot
of flaws.
He really does.
But the idea that the reason her Ronaldo thinks
the Canadian trucker convoy is nuts is because
he at I mean, how old is her?
Although at this point he's going to be close
to 80.
Yes, 78.
The idea that now 78 year old Heraldo, who
has, you know, accumulated assets during the
course of his life.
The reason that he's opposed to the Canadian
trucker convoy and the inciting of the trucker
convoy by Fox News is because he drives a
Bentley.
If that's true or because he has no house
assets, there is no evidence of that whatsoever.
And it's just so funny to hear these very
people who, when it's convenient, they support
the rich guy from queens.
And they don't talk about how Trump's total
totally disconnected from the average working
class American.
When it's convenient, they ignore that.
But then when it's convenient, they'll say,
well, heraldo drives a Bentley and her, although
really struck a chord here, he's absolutely
right that these folks have been inciting,
and at the end of the day, the Canadian trucker
convoy is a reactionary movement.
It's a reactionary movement.
They they want to go to the status quo merely
for the previous status quo, merely because
that's what it was.
They don't want vaccine requirements.
They don't, they don't want anything.
And of course, these things are going to fall
off as we're already seeing them fall off.
But that that you know what, the police, by
the way, oh, I should even mention that there's
a video which I'll play here without audio
of Canadian police shaking hands and hugging
the trucker convoy.
People, when you have the support of the police
as well as of capital in your movement.
You have to consider that it's a reactionary
movement and it's not always the case.
And I want to be careful about making blanket
statements, but the idea that this is some
kind of, you know, working class uprising
representing the predominant opinion in Canada.
There is not a single poll that suggests that
that's what it is.
And some of the main insiders of this entire
thing have been American right wing media